I've got a really interesting little
story that has developed around this
extraordinarily racially tinged ad that
was promoted by Donald Crump this is a
campaign ad that was posted on social
media by Trump last week and many people
are understandably calling it racist it
was at minimum extraordinarily racially
charged and the ad tells the story of an
illegal immigrant who entered the United
States multiple times and was eventually
sentenced to the death penalty for
killing two police officers in 2014 and
the ad asks who else would Democrats let
in and the idea of the ad is just to
frame Democrats as the party that's
going to welcome these violent brown men
into the country regardless of what the
law says and before we even get into the
specifics of the ad this ad was banned
by some television stations okay the
President of the United States promoted
an ad so racist that it was banned on
television take that in for a second the
problem with the content of the ad is
that the Sacramento Bee looked into the
story and it turns out that this man
actually entered the United States when
George W Bush was president and he was
released for unknown reasons from
detention from incarceration by that
vile depraved extremist sheriff joe
arpaio who has since been pardoned
himself by President Donald Trump the
man's name is Luis bracamontes and it
turns out that Bill Clinton had deported
him he came back to the United States
was arrested in Phoenix in 1998 then he
was released by Joe Arpaio we don't know
why and then he was arrested by George W
Bush and deported again in 2001 came
back to the u.s. in 2002 married in
Arizona that year according to records
and later he did end up arrested for
killing two police officers so obviously
this is a tragedy this is horrifying
this is despicable but what is also
despicable is playing politics as if
Democrats are to blame for this guy
Clinton deported him he came back under
Bush
a republican sheriff who's a darling of
donald trump's show a joe arpaio
released him and then he killed people
when President Obama was President of
the United States
there's nothing clear about the
political ideology that's the blame here
if you wanted to push back and play
politics with it from the left you could
say Joe Arpaio is known for treating
inmates terribly was it our pyo's
treatment that push this guy over the
edge to ultimately go and kill two
police officers I'm not making that
argument I'm pointing out how dumb it is
it's that that case I just suggested is
about as logical as the one that the ad
makes that Democrats are somehow
responsible for this guy but like I said
yesterday the truth doesn't matter what
the ad claims about Democrats being
responsible is flat-out false but it
doesn't matter because anybody who's
ignorant or horrible enough to be
influenced by an ad like this will
explain the fact-checking away as fake
news or they simply won't care that
Democrats didn't actually have anything
to do with that guy because it serves
the greater good because Democrats would
allow all sorts of other criminals to
come into the United States it's
depressing and we know Pat from the
calls that we've gotten that it's
getting to a lot of people in the
audience and at this point I feel like
it's just a matter of voting you you do
have control over this type of rhetoric
in the sense that if we turned up our
voter turnout by ten twelve or fifteen
percent the people influenced by ads
like this wouldn't really make a
difference in the elections that's why
I'm just telling everybody Pat you just
gotta go vote today now oh absolutely
and I think under normal circumstances
the right way to rebuke an ad like this
would would be to say that this is just
one anecdotal story and by and large
overall immigrants commit fewer crimes
the native foreign citizens that there
are plenty of native foreign people who
go out there and kill cops but you don't
even have to get into all that stuff
because all you have to do is point out
that he came in under bush and that Joe
Arpaio let him out argument over
yeah and unfortunately some of those
earlier arguments about the crime rate
of undocumented and documented
immigrants we made those claims in our
long-form piece about undocumented
immigration look at some of the comments
if you are ready and please don't let
children see the comments on that video
if you are ready to see the depths of
just the bottom of the barrel of
political discussion look at the
comments on our exposition of the
reality that among other realities
undocumented and documented immigrants
commit crimes at a lower rate than
american-born citizens